[Music]
[Applause]
the holidays are the most magical time
of the year but they're also the busiest
travel season of the year so before you
pack your bags we here at the Amber
Ruffin show have invited an expert
commuter to give you some tips on
stress-free holiday travel so please
welcome Carol the lead character in a
Hallmark holiday movie
's on the red eye to Paris stand he fax
it in before the big meeting or you're
fired oh sorry Amber assistance am I
right
Carol are you really gonna fire your
assistant right before Christmas do I
look like I have time for Christmas
Amber as a no-nonsense businesswoman on
the go I practically live at the airport
and I don't have time for delays detours
or distractions distractions like having
Christmas spirit
or falling in love
well thank you for fitting us into your
busy schedule let's get to it and hear
your holiday travel tips you got it tip
number one book first class that way
when you're on your way to a stressful
event like meeting your fiance Rick's
family for the first time you can just
sit back relax and sip champagne
I mean sure you two haven't set a date
yet and Rick has never made you laugh
but
right but first class is the luxury and
most Americans can only afford to fly
economy which brings me to tip number
two there will inevitably be a ticket
mix-up at the gate and they will try to
put you in economy don't let them go to
the ticket counter and throw a loud
self-important tantrum does that work
rarely but it may get a snide remark out
of that rude yet handsome Stranger in
line behind you someone doesn't have
Christmas spirit
what a jerk you would never fall for a
man like that
sorry is the tip that you should or you
shouldn't go to the ticket counter tip
number three surprise surprise they sat
you in economy next to that rude
handsome stranger Dean he calls himself
you know the cowboy Lumberjack type who
knows how to push all your buttons the
opposite of your fiance
whose Name Escapes you at the moment
what is your tip Carol
and not fall in love with Dean of course
what about
bucks for like if your flight gets
canceled or rerouted due to bad weather
easy tip number four if a snowstorm
reroutes you to some Regional Airport in
a Backcountry town do not let that
Airline put you up in a quaint bed and
breakfast what's wrong with a bed and
breakfast because Dean's there Amber
and there's only one shared hallway
bathroom the last thing you need is Dean
seeing you wet and vulnerable in a towel
you need to get back to your fiance
who you're just not realizing has never
actually said the words I love you and
Dean thinks you deserve better
buddy we gotta refocus here what advice
do you have for travelers who don't get
put up in a hotel and are stranded
overnight at the airport
Carol Dean
that's Dean
what are you what are you doing here I
caught the first flight to New York I
had to come find you it's just I'm busy
at work right now Cameron are you crazy
who cares about holiday travel he's a
Dreamboat
but why would he come looking for me I'm
just an icy girl boss with no Christmas
spirit
no you're not Carol you just
misunderstood and vulnerable I saw you
in that tile remember
but what about Rick who's Rick again her
fiance keep up sorry please keep going
I just wanted to say
because it's Christmas
don't marry Rick marry me
here now in front of all these people
secretly rooting for us
if it's too soon now let's do it next
Christmas in the sequel
a Christmas wedding I like the sound of
that oh sorry lifetime already did that
one
you know what let's just elope screw it
deal yeah give it up for Carol and Dean
everyone
Mary loves them
[Music]
[Applause]